[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
metri Serien einen schönen Sonntagabend
ihnen allen das sportliche später wieder
mit Christian Otto viel los im Schnee
gut und hier sind die Themen des Tages
Korruptions Skandal im EU-Parlament
weitet sich aus vier Verdächtige sitzen
mittlerweile in U-Haft darunter wohl
auch parlamentsvize kaii
neue Züge neue Strecken höhere Preise
mit dem Winterfahrplan will die Deutsche
Bahn hin zu einer besseren zugtaktung
und zurück auf der Erde nach fast einem
Monat im All landet die unbemannte
Raumkapsel der Mondmission Artemis im
Pazifik
[Musik]
die Paukenschläge im Zusammenhang mit
der Korruptionsaffäre im EU-Parlament
werden lauter Brüsseler Justizbehörden
erließen Haftbefehl gegen vier
Verdächtige offenbar auch gegen die
vizeparlamentspräsidentin kaii der
griechischen Sozialdemokratin werden
Geldwäsche und Bestechung vorgeworfen
der Golf statt Katha soll mit hohen
geldsum versucht haben die Arbeit des
Europaparlaments zu beeinflussen am
Samstagabend wurde auch das Haus des
belgischen Europaabgeordneten tarabella
durchsucht
Gunnar Krüger ist für uns in Brüssel was
bedeuten diese Haftbefehle für den
Fortgang dieser Affäre
ja das bedeutet erstmal natürlich dass
sie fort dauert dass das Europaparlament
dieser Affäre so schnell nicht
abschütteln kann es gibt ja gleich zwei
neue Kapitel das eine schreibt eben
dieser belgische Abgeordnete auch ein
Sozialdemokrat der marktarabella der
erstaunliche Wandel der war einfach auch
zu augenfällig ja galt mal als scharfer
Kritiker einer WM in Katar und jetzt in
derselben Debatte wie evakali da hat er
gesagt jetzt muss ich jetzt auch mal gut
sein mit dem Katar Bashing also solche
Meinungen kann man haben man darf sie
sich aber eben nicht bezahlen lassen und
das zweite Kapitel das schreibt Eva
Kylie selbst nach ZDF Recherchen hat sie
an der Sitzung eines Ausschusses
teilgenommen der überwieser
Erleichterungen für Kater abstimmen
sollte und sie hat sogar an der
Abstimmung selbst teilgenommen obwohl
sie nicht mehr Mitglied dieses
Ausschusses ist das ist natürlich
aufgefallen aber man muss sozusagen im
Sinne von Katar sagen wenn wirklich Geld
geflossen sein sollte dann hat sie für
dieses Geld was getan die gute Nachricht
ist dieser Ausschuss der nimmt die
Entscheidung jetzt noch mal zurück so
schnell werden wie Erleichterungen für
Katar nicht kommen danke nach Brüssel
Gunnar Krüger und weitere Infos zu
kaelis Rolle in diesem Ausschuss finden
Sie dann auch auf ZDF heute
Kriegstag
291 weiterhin schwere Angriffe auf das
ukrainische Energienetz ausgerechnet wo
jetzt der Winter anzieht soll etwa die
Großstadt Odessa für Wochen ohne Strom
sein Volker ducek beginnt seinen Bericht
im dornbas wo der Verkehrsknotenpunkt
Bach Mut unter massiven russischen
Beschuss genommen wurde
70.000 Menschen haben hier vor dem Krieg
gelebt 90% der Bevölkerung sind geflohen
vor den Russen dienen
bachmut-ukrainische Nachschublinien
unterbrechen wollen
im ukrainischen Fernsehen sagt ein
Sprecher des Heeres im Osten russland
habe seine Taktik geändert anstelle von
Angriffen größerer Einheiten erfolgen
jetzt Attacken durch kleinere Gruppen
nach Einschätzung der ukrainischen Armee
soll es sich dabei auch um Einheiten der
Söldnertruppe Wagner Handeln unterstützt
von der Artillerie
neben bachmuthem don-bass nehmen die
Angreifer verstärkt die Millionenstadt
Odessa ins Visier
vor diesem Café hat der Gastwirt extra
Notstromaggregate aufgestellt sie sorgen
dafür dass die Bilder von der Fußball-WM
bis ins ukrainische Kriegsgebiet reichen
und deshalb ist schwer getroffen von
iranischen Drohnen wieder ukrainische
Präsident sagt
zur Zeit sind mehr als 1,5 Millionen
Menschen ohne Strom nur kritische
Infrastrukturen sind noch ans Netz
angeschlossen
bis das Stromnetz repariert ist werden
Wochen vergehen und der Winter kommt im
Bahnhof in Odessa haben die Behörden
Wärmestuben mit Holzöfen eingerichtet
wir können die Menschen auch ihre Handys
Laden solange es noch genug Diesel für
die Stromgeneratoren gibt
nach der Großrazzia im Reichsbürger
Milieu plant Innenministerin faesar eine
Verschärfung des Waffenrechts mehr als
1000 sogenannten reichsbürgern habe man
die Waffenerlaubnis schon entzogen in
der Bild am Sonntag die Ministerin
warnte vor einer wachsenden Gefahr durch
die Szene
Bahnkunden kennen das oft sieht man vom
Zug nur die Rücklichter weil der
Anschluss eben nicht klappt das soll
besser werden sagt die Bahn ab heute
gilt der neue Fahrplan und das
Unternehmen verspricht mehr Züge engere
Taktung kürzere Fahrzeiten und den
Ausbau des Fernverkehrs das alles hat
aber auch seinen Preis Silvia blessmann
schneller will die Bahn werden teurer
ist sie bereits die Ticketpreise steigen
inflationsbedingt um durchschnittlich
4,9%. auch bei den Bahncards Beispiel
Bahncard 50 sie wird 10 Euro Mehrkosten
die flex-ticketpreise steigen um knapp
7% nur superspar und Sparpreise ändern
sich nicht natürlich wird alles teurer
ja da bleibt noch die Bahn nicht
verschont wenn das stimmt das mehr Züge
fahren und die dann vielleicht auch noch
pünktlich sind dann wäre finde ich okay
aber das wird nicht passieren
angekündigt sind für die
hochgeschwindigkeitsflotte so viele neue
ICE wie nie zuvor
2023 werden 37 neue Expresszüge in
Dienst gestellt mit 19000 mehr
Sitzplätzen die Fahrgäste werden in
einigen Punkten eine etwas bessere
Leistung haben aber ein wirklich großen
Durchbruch das heißt also mehr
pünktlichkeit wird es zur Zeit nicht
geben denn überall am Schienennetz wird
gebaut was lange vernachlässigt wurde
wird endlich fit gemacht
von 2030 will die Bahn doppelt so viel
Fahrgäste transportieren
also wir haben eine knappe Infrastruktur
die außerdem noch alt und störanfällig
ist wir glauben trotzdem dass wir im
nächsten Jahr eine bessere Pünktlichkeit
hinbekommen zu Weihnachten sollen etwa
80 Sonderzüge Rollen voll dürfte es dann
noch werden
ganz anderes wären jetzt vor knapp einer
halben Stunde ist die Raumkapsel Orion
von ihrem Testflug zur Erde
zurückgekehrt in rund zwei Jahren soll
sie Astronauten zum Mond bringen und
später auch zu einer neuen Raumstation
die soll dann als Beobachtungsposten und
Hightech Labor um den mondkreisen
außerdem Teil der NASA artemismission
eine Basis auf dem Mond in der man leben
und forschen kann über den erfolgreichen
Testflug jetzt Claudia Bates
an Fallschirmen schwebt die Raumkapsel
langsam in den Pazifik dabei liegt der
dramatischste Moment der Mission gerade
hinter ihr mit einer Geschwindigkeit von
40.000 Stundenkilometern ist Orion in
die Erdatmosphäre eingetreten die
kritischste Phase das Hitzeschild musste
Temperaturen von rund 2800 Grad
standhalten
und beim nächsten Mal sollen in der
Kapsel ja Menschen mit fliegen
wir werden noch für zwei Stunden im
Wasser sein und die letzten Tests machen
wir müssen untersuchen wie die starke
Hitze beim Wiedereintritt sich im
Inneren der Kapsel auswirkt
nach dem spektakulären Start mit der
neuen riesenrakete umrundete Orion den
Mond eine Woche lang alle Ziele hat sie
erreicht den Vorbeiflug am Mond in nur
rund 100 km Entfernung das Einschwenken
in dessen Umlaufbahn der Mond fast
greifbar mehr als zwei Millionen
Kilometer hat die Raumkapsel
zurückgelegt im Moment läuft alles auf
eine erfolgreiche Mission hinaus wir
konnten sogar mehr erreichen als geplant
nun wird die Mission ausgewertet den
Blick fest darauf gerichtet wie der
Menschen auf den Mond zu bringen und
schließlich auf den Mars das Ende der
Mission Artemis 1 der Beginn einer neuen
Raumfahrt Ära
tolle Bilder Christian jetzt sind wir
beim Sport beim Wintersport absolut so
muss es sein flott zum Skispringen
Weltcup in Titisee-Neustadt mit Karl
Geiger als besten deutschen auf Platz 5
Tagessieger der Pole David Kubatzki das
große Erfolgserlebnis für die Gastgeber
gab es bei den Frauen durch Katharina
Althaus
die Oberstdorferin von ihren
Teamkolleginnen auf den Schultern
getragen nach tagesbest weiter auf der
Hochfirst Schanze
Althaus fliegt im zweiten Durchgang auf
137 Meter und gewinnt vor der Norwegerin
Silvio obset und usabuga Thai aus
Slowenien für die 26-Jährige beste
deutsche skispringerin im fünften
Weltcup dieser Saison der dritte
Podiumsplatz und der zweite Sieg sowie
die Führung im Gesamtweltcup
mit insgesamt drei Weltcupsiegen hat
sich die deutsche Rodel Elite in
Whistler Kanada eindrucksvoll
zurückgemeldet bei den Doppelsitzern
gewann das Duo Toni Eckert Sascha
Benecken vor ihren Teamkollegen Tobias
wendel Tobias Arl zudem markierte
Deutschland auch die Bestzeit im
Staffelwettbewerb
und Ruhetag bei der Fußball-WM in Katar
auch die Franzosen sind im Halbfinale
durch das 2:1 gegen die Engländer bei
denen ausgerechnet der Kapitän zur
tragischen Figur wurde so sehr Harry
Kane die englischen Fans auch mit seinem
ersten Elfmeter Schuss zum 1:1 beglückt
so sprachlos macht er sie mit seinem
zweiten Strafstoß in der 84 Minute
[Applaus]
so wird es nichts mehr mit einem zwei zu
zwei gegen Frankreich die
Titelverteidiger gehen in dieser
hochklassigen Partie früh durch
tour-mini in Führung und das gelingt den
Franzosen nach Cains gelungenem ersten
Strafstoß gleich noch einmal der 2:1
Sieg Treffer durch Olivier Chirurg Harry
Kane direkt nach Schlusspfiff
untröstlich ohne seine Treffer und seine
Führungsqualitäten wären wir nie so weit
gekommen
mit etwas Abstand trösten dürften
ohne England Dienstag und Mittwochabend
die Halbfinals schauen wir mal wer da
ein richtig runter Zimmer ne so danke
Christin wir hätten auch die
Wetteraussichten morgen fällt in
Brandenburg und in Sachsen Schnee sonst
ist es meist trocken die Sonne zeigt
sich immer häufiger im Osten wird ein
bürgerwind die Temperaturen zwischen -4
und plus 3 Grad die kommende Tage die
bleiben ähnlich kalt im Süden schneit es
dann zeitweise das heute journal um
21:45 Uhr mit Marie das lomka wir
wünschen noch einen angenehmen
Adventsabend und sehen uns dann morgen